Now we have a very simple program. I'm going to do volume 12, beginning at April 18, 1917.
I'm going to do it for an hour. Then I'm going to give you about 15-minute break. Then we'll
do another hour. Then you'll have lunch. Then you'll have another hour. And then you'll
have another hour. Is that okay?
So April 18, 1917, this is volume 12. So this is April 18, 1917. This is about fusing oneself
in the divine will.
Louisa said, "I was fusing myself in my sweet Jesus in order to be able to diffuse myself
in all creatures and to fuse them all in Jesus." Now I want you to notice that I'm
not fusing just for myself alone. I'm fusing myself in order to be able to diffuse myself
in all creatures and to fuse them in Jesus. This entire mission that we are part of is
to give mactimum glory to God, that is his Jew, and also to make reparation and substitution
for the rest of humanity and to save as many souls as possible. So that's a vital point
there. As you keep thinking, loving, repairing, et cetera, the rays of the sun is formed.
And my will as background makes itself the crown of these rays. And the sun is formed,
which rising up into the air melts into a beneficial Jew for all people.
So the more you fuse yourself in me, the more suns keep forming. Now a sun is a source
of light. God is light and Jesus told us that we have to be the light of the world.
So that's Matthew 5 and I think it's verse 14, somewhere between 14 and 17. Oh how beautiful
it is to see these suns, which rising and rising remain circumfused within my own suns.
So these are little lights in the light and they pour a beneficial Jew over all. Now notice
the universalism of anything that God does because Jesus says in these writings that
God loves each human being as much as he loves the whole. So if the whole are not benefited,
then we're not loving the way he loves. How many graces do souls not receive? I'm so
taken by this, Jesus said, that as they fuse themselves, I pour abundant Jew of all kinds
of graces upon them. That's upon you, the people who are actually doing the fusing.
So that they can form even greater suns. Now I want you to check out John 15 there. Fruit
more fruit and much fruit and fruit that will last. Okay, the Lord is all is like the farmer
who looks for a better harvest next year and an even better one the year after such that
I may be able to pour more abundantly the beneficial Jew over all. Now why does he want us producing
more fruit? It is so that the benefits will be given in a greater and greater way to everybody
else. So we have to be fusing ourselves and him as frequently as possible to someone at
the door. And as I was fusing myself, Louisa said, I could feel light, love and graces
being poured over my head. So there we've started on a very good point that we need
to be fusing all the time to make sure that this incredible divine Jew is being poured
out upon the human race. So May 2nd, 1917, how Jesus died little by little. And since
we're at the beginning of Lent, we also die little by little. We don't die all of a sudden.
So finding myself in my usual state, I was lamenting to my sweet Jesus because of his
privations saying to him, my love, who could ever think that your privation could have
cost me so much? I feel myself dying little by little. Each act of mine is a death that
I feel because I cannot find a life. But dying and living is even more cruel. Even more,
it is a double death. So the experience that Louisa is having of the privations of Jesus
is quite literally a martyrdom for her. And Jesus acknowledges that and explains it to
her as well. So Jesus came and he said, my daughter courage and firmness in everything.
Now what the translator writes down is firmness. You should write down as fortitude. Fortitude
is one of the great gifts of God to us. And I call it steel girders for your soul. When
people are building skyscrapers and very high buildings that they want to survive hurricanes
and major disasters, they put steel girders into them. And they go right very deep into
the earth and as high as possible so that the building can survive a terrible shock.
Well the fortitude that the Lord wants to put into us is what enables us to survive
spiritual shocks. And then he said, don't you want to imitate me? I too died little
by little. As people offended me in their steps, I felt the tearing in my feet. But with such
bitterness of spasm as to be capable of giving me death. And while I would feel myself dying,
yet I would not die. As they offended me in their works, the first thing is in their steps,
the second thing in their works, I felt death in my hands. And at the cruel torment I agonized,
I felt faint, but the will of the father sustained me. I would die and I would not die. He's
trying to explain to Louisa that the privations that she's experiencing are a participation
in his passion. And that she needs to let this mystery happen in her more quietly than
she is prone to do it. So number three, Jesus said, as the evil voices, the horrendous blasphemies
of creatures reverberated in my voice, I felt myself suffocating, my word being choked and
poisoned. And I felt death in my voice, but I wouldn't die. And my tortured heart, this
is number four. As it palpitated, I felt in my heartbeat, the evil lives, souls tearing
themselves away. And my heart was in a continuous tearing and lacerations. Now Jesus is saying
that this was happening all during his lifetime, but it's happening ever since in the Eucharist
in his Eucharistic presence. And so he said, I agonized and I died continuously in each
soul. Instead of the word creature, I'm putting soul. And I've only one comment in my book
for me and it's out. So if you go back and read that, that in all my evil words, steps,
words, works, and so on, he has agonized for me. Now that was the thing that Saint Augustine
said changed everything for him. He died for me. He actually undid all the evil that I
I have done. And that's the thing that makes us truly come round and actually love him.
So he said, I agonized and I died continuously in each soul in each offense, yet love the
divine will forced me to live. This is the reason for your dying little by little. So
here is another explanation of her privations. As we go through these writings, Jesus explains
the privations to her from different angles. So it was the divine will, which is love.
I've told you that the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love because God
is love one John four seven and God is the divine will. So love was the reason why Jesus
made reparation for all the rest of us. And love is the reason why he asks us to enter
into the divine will and to make reparation and substitution for everybody else. I call
that pouring my drop of water into the wine of his redemption. So it's my participation.
So he said, I want you together with me. I want your company in my debts. In other words,
he wants each one of us in our own small tiny way to be co redeemers with him. And look
at the extraordinary humility of God there that he could say, I'll do it all by myself.
Human beings do that, don't they? They want to get all the glory for themselves. But instead
of that, Jesus wants us to actually participate with him in his redeeming. And when you come
to chapter 3 of the book of Revelation, he says, I will let you share my throne as well.
He's the only king who ever wanted anybody to share his throne. So May the 10th 1917,
how with his breath, Jesus gives motion and life to all creatures. Now the breath is the
Holy Spirit, the third person of the Blessed Trinity. And in Hebrew, it's called Roach
Adonai, or UACH is Roach. A-D-O-N-A-I is Adonai. And we translate that in English as the breath
of God. Breathe on me, breath of God. You know that hymn? Now the breath of God is the
source of life. You will see that if you go back to Genesis 2, 7, that Adam did not become
a living being until the breath of God was poured into him. When you go to John chapter
20 and verse 22, you'll find that Jesus had formed the church in the 12 Apostles, ending
up with 11. But they were literally not able to go out and be church until after the resurrection
when he breathed upon them and gave them the Holy Spirit. Okay, so that's Genesis 2, 7
and John 20, 22. That's just to show you how central the breath is. And of course the
name that the Hebrew people gave to God was this, Yah, wait, that's my out breath and
my in breath. So the sacred name that they actually don't pronounce is my very breath.
Or if I gave you that in English, I am because he is. I cannot live unless he lives. My daughter
Jesus said, the person is nothing other than my breath or the soul. As I breathe, I give
life to everything. All life is in the breathing. As I shared with one of the groups just very
recently, a lovely experience I had in South Africa in Pretoria, giving a retreat there
some years ago. It was that in the local hospital on one level of the hospital, an old man died
at exactly 11 o'clock in the morning. And his grandson on another level was born at
exactly 11 a.m. the same morning. And so when we had the funeral for the granddad, we spoke
about the breath of God being breathed in at the first point of life and being given
back to God. And so we are called a breathing living planet because of the fact that the
breath of life is breathed in and breathed out. So that's why they would use that expression
for God, the breathing in and the breathing out. All life is in the breathing Jesus said,
but there's no breathing, the heart no longer beats, the blood no longer circulates, the
hands remain inactive, the mind feels the intelligence die and so with all the rest.
Sam 1 4 6 verse 4. Sam 1 4 6 verse 4. So the whole of human life is in receiving and giving
this breath, which I've just illustrated. But while with my breath, I give life and
motion to all creatures. And with my holy breath, I want to sanctify them, love them,
embellish them, enrich them, etc. In giving me the breath they receive, they send me or
fences, rebellions in gratitude, blasphemies, denials and all the rest. You can only give
what you have. He gives us love and life. And if we're in an unredeemed state, we give
back that unredeemed state to him continuously. So I send the breath as pure and it comes
back to me impure. Now the fullest meaning of the word impure means that there is contamination
in the thing. All of us love beautiful music, but if some of the notes are off, it's really
terrible and you won't listen to it. In other words, the notes are impure. A lovely fresh
glass of water is a wonderful thing to drink, but if there are impurities in it, you wouldn't
touch it. So if there are impurities in our love, our service, our prayer, our intercessions,
and we've spoiled the whole thing. Did you get the point? Jesus said, "I send the breath
as a blessing and it comes back to me as cursing. I send it out all love and it comes back to
me or fending me deep into my inmost heart. But love makes me continue to send the breath
and to maintain these machines of human lives." I love that expression. I think this is the
only time in these volumes that the human being is called a machine. Otherwise, they
would no longer function and they would end up in ruin. Now notice the incredible love
of God that regardless of the response that is given back to him, he continues to love
because God is love. That's who he is. Jesus said, "Am I daughter, have you heard how
human life is maintained by my breath? Please turn off all mobile phones, will you?"
Human life is maintained by my breath. And when I find a soul who loves me, how sweet
her breath is, how she delights me, I feel cheered. So when we love him, our breath is
going back to him as love. So love is meeting love. How she delights me, now the translator
says, "Am uses me." In English, we don't use amuses in this context. We say delight.
Echo of harmonies forms between me and the soul, which remain distinct from all other
people. In other words, God is able to distinguish, "That's my Mary. That's my John." That there's
something very distinctive about each one of us and that's why you've heard me say over
the years that it is extremely important for each one of us to give back our own unique
response to God. That we don't just give back some kind of a general response to God.
There is a unique note in your response that is in nobody else. So let me read that again.
An echo of harmonies forms between me and her, which remain distinct from other people
and will be distinct also in heaven as terribly important. "My daughter, I could not contain
my love and I wanted to pour it out with you," he said. So today, Louisa said, "I could
not fuse myself in Jesus because he himself kept me occupied in his breath. How many things
I understood, but I'm unable to say them all and I stop here." Okay. So I want you to
hear that uniqueness that the Lord is touching there so that we will not just be robots repeating
back other words, even if they're very wonderful words. That doesn't mean that you can't use
prayers in the divine will, but just make sure that you make them yours. Like the prayer
you're looking at, that you just understand what it is saying and then give it to the
Lord in your words so that he's hearing you and not somebody else. So May the 12th, 1917,
one who doubts about the love of Jesus saddens him. "Since my beloved Jesus had not come
and I was very afflicted, while I was praying a thought flew through my mind, did the thought
ever come to you that you might be lost?" Guess where that's coming from. "I never really
think about this," said Louisa, "naturally because her whole mind and her whole being
is occupied with the Lord." So why should she be thinking thoughts like that? So I remained
a bit surprised. "But good Jesus who watches over me in everything, Sam 139, moved immediately
in my interior," which means he's actually there. So that's Luke 17, 21, "The Kingdom
of God is within you." Now do you think that that thought is a problem that Louisa has?
The answer is no. In these writings, the Lord often allows Louisa to appear to have a problem
which is not actually her own, but because these writings are for the generations that
come after Louisa. So it's you and I can have the temptation, maybe this is all fancy stuff,
and maybe I could be lost in the end that I could be deceived. And so the Lord answers
that for us. My daughter, he said, "This is true strangeness," which saddens my love
very much. That love should have a capital L because it's divine. If a daughter said
to her father, "I am not your daughter," you will not give me a share in your inheritance.
You don't want to give me food. You don't want to keep me in your house and she torments
herself and sends out laments. What would the poor father say, "Strangeness, this daughter
is crazy." And with all love he would say to her, "But tell me, if you're not my daughter,
who's daughter, are you? How is this? You live under my roof. You don't have to say
my same roof. You live under my roof. You eat at my table. I clotude you with my money.
I errand by my own sweat. If you are ill, I assist you and I procure the means to heal
you. And you doubt about being my daughter." Now what Jesus is saying there is, not talking
to Louisa because it's not her problem. If you are in relationship with Jesus and if
you are loving him and if you are responding to him and you are trying to be close to him,
why would you doubt? Why would you doubt? Now it's satan that wants to insinuate the
thought maybe you're just deceiving yourself. I remember many, many years ago. In fact it
was the first time I ever spoke to a large crowd and I was walking into the hall to give
my teaching. It was a scripture teaching and I was all alone and this crowd was several
hundred people who were waiting for me and I heard this guttural voice over my shoulder
and looked around and I didn't see anything and the guttural voice said, "If they knew
what you were like, they wouldn't listen to you." Now I'm one of these people that
can think of a brilliant answer two days later. But the Lord gave me an extraordinary grace
to answer him immediately and the answer lies in the words of Jesus. "The truth will set
you free." So I turned to that voice and there was no figure there and I said, "I am bad
enough. You make it worse. Get the hell out of here." He never tried it again. Ever.
I was not pretending to be good. I was not pretending to be a saint. I was not pretending
to be better than anybody else and the reason why I'm giving you that example is that when
all of us go to Dromantine, we're not going because we're better than anybody else. We're
not going because we know anything more than anybody else. That's absolutely not the reason
why we're going. We're just simply going to give glory to God and to love each other
in divine love. And when you are completely clear about it, if the guttural voice may
not come as strongly as that to you, most of the time Satan will slither a little thought
into your head. Should I couldn't possibly do that, sure? I mean, what do I know? That's
coming from outside. And just get rid of it. You're not going because you know everything
about anything or anything about everything. That's not the reason why we're going. We're
going to give glory to God and to love one another with divine love. So Jesus said, "Why
would you doubt?" You see, the thing he loves most is surrender and trust. And surrender
and trust are the two wings of the eagle. And I introduced you to the eagle a long time
ago. Okay. Surrender and trust. We surrender absolutely to God and we trust him beyond
reason. The Lord told me some years ago to tell everybody I ever addressed that in the
years to come. Now he gave me this about 10 years ago. He said, "In the years to come,
you are going to need this as much as you need air. You must trust me beyond reason."
Now that the chastisement has started, we knew it was going to come in 2020. Now that
it has started, trust him beyond reason. Is that okay? You'll be okay. And everybody
around you will be okay if you trust him beyond reason because you will have brought God and
his presence and his grace and his glory into your circumstances and into your situation.
So you don't doubt that you are his daughter or his son. With more reason, Jesus said,
"I would say to one who doubts about my love and feared that she might be lost." How is
this? Watch this. Number one, I give you my flesh for food. Did all of us receive Holy
Communion today? But how on earth could you go to hell? Hell wouldn't have you. Hell would
throw you out. You're now one of us. Does the logic of that strike you? Yeah. He said,
"I give you my flesh for food to keep you completely my own." Number two, if you are
ill, now you're speaking about spiritual illnesses, I heal you with my sacraments. Do you go to
confession when you need? Of course. Do we run to him as the healer? If you are stained,
I wash you with my blood. One, two and three. To give you absolute, he's trying to give
each one of us absolute assurance that we are his. I can say that I am almost at your
disposal and you doubt? You want to sadden me? Tell me then. Do you love somebody else?
Do you recognize some other being as your father? Father means origin. I comes from the
word abba, which means origin. Who says that you are not my daughter? And if this is not,
why do you want to afflict yourself and sadden me? Isn't the bitterness that others people
give me enough that you shouldn't add anymore pains to my heart? In other words, for those
of us who are living as much as we can in the divine will, it would sadden the Lord terribly
if we doubted the reality of what is happening within us, sadden him terribly. In other words,
it would mean people who are trying to live at the highest level of holiness would actually
have a doubt in their heads, but sadden doesn't let you off the hook. So it's a good warning
to you. Okay. On May the 16th, 1917, we get a lovely reflection on the hours of the Passion
and I think it's a very important one. Finding myself in my usual state, I was fusing all
of myself in my sweet Jesus. Now, I've mentioned that to some of you recently that we should
say to the Lord, quite frequently, I fuse all of me in all of you. Now, notice Louisa
is fusing all of herself. She's keeping nothing back. And then I poured all of myself into
souls. You see, if I fuse all of myself in Jesus, then I can diffuse all of myself into
souls in order to give the whole out of them to Jesus. Isn't it wonderful? And my beloved
Jesus told me, my daughter, every time you fuse yourself in me, you give to all souls
the influence of divine life. Now, put VIP and anything else you can put on that or color
it in a major color. Every single time you fuse yourself in Jesus, you give the influence
of divine life to all souls. What do the people in this country and every country need more
than air only the influence of divine life? Okay. And according to what they need, they
will obtain their effect. So watch this. You're simply fusing all of you in all of him so
that this divine influence will go out to all. And he decides who gets what according
to their disposition. Those who are weak will get strength. Those who are obstinate in
sin will receive light. And those who suffer will receive comfort and all the rest. It's
only given examples. There's lots of others. I think that's fantastic, don't you? Then
I found myself outside of myself, Louisa said. So she's in and out of the body experience.
I was in the midst of many souls who were saying to me, she said they seemed to be purging
souls and saints. So she got the mixture of the whole family. And they were mentioning
one person known to me who died not too long ago, and they were saying to me, watch this
now. He feels as though happy in seeing that there's not one soul who enters purgatory
without carrying the mark of the hours of the passion. Please put a huge VIP. He feels
as though happy in seeing that there's not one soul who enters purgatory without carrying
the mark of the hours of the passion. And surrounded by the courtage of these hours and
helped by them, souls find a safe place. Look what we're doing for other people in doing
the hours of the passion. Isn't it incredible? And there's not one soul. Look at that, I didn't
write it. There's not one soul who flies into heaven without being accompanied by these
hours of the passion. Notice why the prayer needs to go past as well as present, as well
as future. These hours make a continuous Jew reign down from heaven to earth into purgatory
and even into heaven itself. Talk about ministering to the whole church, the church in heaven,
the church on earth and the church in purgatory. Isn't that absolutely amazing? On hearing
this, Louisa said, maybe my beloved Jesus in order to keep the word that he gave me, that
for each word of the hours of the passion he would give a soul, there's not one soul
whom he saves who does not benefit from these hours. That's where you get this message,
that for every word of the hours of the passion he would save a soul. But if you just simply
read them, it doesn't work. It's only when you pray the hours of the passion in the divine
will that souls are saved. If you just read them as an ordinary devotion, no. It must
be done specifically fused in the divine will. So afterwards, Louisa said, I returned
into myself and as I found my sweet Jesus, I asked him whether this was true. And Jesus
said, these hours are the order of the universe. Now, that's not an answer I was expecting.
They put heaven and earth in harmony. They hold me back from sending the world to ruin.
I feel my blood, my wounds, my love and everything I did being placed in circulation. And they
flow over all that's past, present and future. So that's your PPF there in order to save everyone.
And as souls do these hours of the passion, I feel my blood, my wounds, my yearnings to
save souls being put on the way. And I feel my life being repeated. How could creatures
obtain any good, if not by means of these hours? So I don't think you and I could even
imagine how much the souls in pargatory want us to pray the hours of the passion. Why do
you doubt? He said, this thing is not yours. It's mine. You have been the strained and
weak instrument. Now, I put a few little ticks after that. He continuously uses weak instruments
and we're under pressure and we're strained. And many of us are stained as well. But he
doesn't mind. I mean, if you have a pencil, that's not the most beautiful pencil and it
may even be broken at the back. But if the pencil actually works brilliantly, wouldn't
you use it? Of course you would. Do I need this pen to have gold and silver on it? Not
at all, so long as the ink actually works. And the point is that if we will actually
let the Lord do His work in us and through us, our faults and failings are now bothered
to Him. I'm sure that theologians would hit me over the head for saying that. But actually
they're not. We're inclined, particularly looking back at the way we were trained when
we were kids, you know, we're inclined to look back and if there's the smallest drawback
in me, God couldn't possibly use me. Forget that. He is the only one who knows how to
write straight with crooked lines. The only thing that worries him is that if you put
your will into a sin or a fault, then you put a block between you and him. Okay? He doesn't
mind using strained and weak instruments. That to me, I read that from my comfort. I don't
know about you. So June the 7th, 1917, the soul remains separated from Jesus when she
lets something that does not belong to Him enter into herself. This is the only bit that
can hold you back from the divine will. Finding myself in my usual state, I was lamenting
to my sweet Jesus because of His privations and was saying to Him, "What bitter separation
separated from you? Everything is over. I have remained the most unhappy soul that can
exist." Okay? So for that, I want to give you Sam 63, the whole of it, and Sam 42. I'll
just give you a few bits from Sam 42. I have nothing but tears for my bread, night and
day, as I keep saying, "Where is your God?" And Louisa, it's like as if it was written
for her. So Jesus interrupted her and He said, "My daughter, what separation are you fishing
for? I love the expression. Do you see that? I mean, where do you think the break is? By
volume 12, Louisa and Jesus are already inseparable, they have become one. So if you have become
one, where are you going to get the separation?" Okay? But of course, the lesson is for you
and me. It's not really for Louisa. Only when she lets something that does not belong to
me enter into herself, then is the soul separated from me. Okay? So at this moment, we are fused
in the divine will. We are reading and thinking about this material in the divine will. But
if I let a little bit of selfishness into me, then I put a block. Or since I'm the one that's
speaking to you, if I put a little bit of pride into me that I'm somehow better than you because
I'm doing this and you're listening to it, I'm switched off. Something that doesn't belong
to Him will make the break. Is that clear? So this is why we've got to watch ourselves
very carefully. And one of the things that I think we should do very carefully in Lent
is if I have said or done something, instead of concentrating on the thing that I've said
or done is to go into myself and say, "Why did you do it? Why did you say it?" Because
if you go back into the why, you're going back into the roots. And if you can confess,
I said that negative thing to somebody because then the priest knows he has somebody who
is actually repenting. If I can tell him the why. So the why is terribly important. Therefore
Jesus said, "I enter into the soul and if I find her will my own." See, that's the issue.
Okay. "I find her desires, her affections, her thoughts, her heart. I find everything
as my own. Then I absorb her into myself." That's John 14, 20 to 21. You and me and I
and you. And with the fire of my love, I keep liquefying her will with me. Now I love this
expression. So would you put a little heading on this paragraph, liquefying the human will?
That's pretty strong language, you know. Liquefying. Because that means then that the human will
surrender completely. Liquefying her will with mine, making them one. I liquefy her desires
with mine. So that means we end up only with his desires. I liquefy her affections, which
means we end up with his way of loving. I liquefy her thoughts with mine. So we sink
the same as Christ. So beside that, I want you to put Philippians chapter two. And I
think it's verses one to four. Everyone must think like Christ. You must have the mind
of Christ. And then of course, if you go on in Philippians chapter two, his state was
divine and he didn't cling to his equality with God and became one of us humbly yet accepting
death. And you have the whole downward movement of humiliation before you have the exaltation.
So our minds must be like him. We must think like him. And once I have formed one single
liquid. Now, if you look at this, I have a glass of water. If I had two glasses with
half of the water each and poured them into the one glass, can you separate the water
afterwards? No, they've become one. There's absolutely no way you can separate them. That's
what Jesus is saying. And that's why the query as, you know, am I your daughter? Am
I separated from you? It doesn't make any sense if you've become totally one. No scientist
on earth could separate one section of that water from the other. It's totally fused.
Is that okay? So he said, "Once I have formed one single liquid, I pour it over my whole
humanity like celestial Jew." Now, I think that is utterly divine. He says, "The few
people who will allow me to bring them to this stage where their will is liquefied with
mine." He said, "That is the Jew that actually gives me the comfort in my humanity." So
we do an incredible service to Jesus by surrendering ourselves to him. I pour it over my whole
humanity like celestial Jew. And as it forms into as many drops of Jew as there are offenses
that I receive, they kiss me, they love me, they repair me, they embalm my bitter wounds,
it is my absolute surrender. Letting my will being taken up into the divine will automatically
have this effect on him. And so it will do the reparation and the comforting of Jesus
in his passion. It's incredible. And it means that, of course, he knew everything because
he's God. So he knew that I was going to reach this point. So I actually participate
in his passion. And so when I go into the hours of the passion, I'm there. I'm actually
present. I'm not just in my house saying these wonderful prayers. I'm actually there
at the time. It's terribly important. And since I'm in the act of doing good, now this
act of doing good is permanent and continuous. This Jew descends for the good of all creatures.
And I want to give you one John, three, two for that. And you'll notice that anything
we do must be for the good of all creatures. He doesn't let us off the hook on that one.
But now we've had this glorious oneness, okay? But if I find something extraneous in the
soul, which doesn't belong to me, I cannot melt what is hers with mine, because love
alone is what has the power of melting and becoming one. So that means there's something
on loving found in me. There's a very telling text in Ezekiel, it's around chapter 26,
where the prophet speaks about the fall of Lucifer. And in it, he says, you were the
most beautiful one until pride was found in you. Then you have the fall. The sin is what
destroys everything. So the something extraneous to the divine will is something that I want
for me. Therefore I am no longer willing to live a surrendered life. Now remember the
wonderful statement of St. John of the Cross that love can be repaid by love alone. But
since you are parents and you've raised children, you know that in your experience anyway. If
a child tried to pay you back with money for what you have done for them, it would only
be an insult. There's only one response and that is love must be returned as love. And
when the love is returned as love, the parent feels completely paid. Am I right? Yeah. Because
love is a cycle. Sin is a cycle and love is a cycle. So love goes out and does something
for another. And then that other must send love back to its source. And then the cycle
will continue on and on and on. Sin is the exact opposite. It actually breaks the love
cycle and creates a devastation cycle on the earth. So love alone has the power of melting
and becoming one. So that's why the image of marriage is used by all writers, including
the Song of Songs and all our saints and mystics for the union of the soul with God and the
union of the church with Christ because it's a surrender in love. Things that are similar
are those that can mix together and can have the same value. Therefore, if in the soldiers
iron and torn and stones, how can they melt? Now, notice iron, thorns and stones, they're
all hard. They're all unbending. And if you put the torns, they're also wounding. Okay.
So that's the sinfulness that's in us. And then there are separations and unhappiness.
So if nothing is entered into your heart, you said, how can I separate? So I want to
give you one John two six, one John two six and verse 10 as well. And one John three six.
So I want to go to June the 14th, 1917. This is a very important message and it's about
stripping. So it's a very good Lenten message. So this is June the 14th. Continue in my usual
state. I was praying my beloved Jesus to come into me in order to love, pray, repair for
I knew how to do nothing and sweet Jesus moved to compassion for my nothingness. Now that's
John 15 five without me, you can do nothing. And we need to have that one absolutely in
our head all the time because that will make us throw ourselves upon God. So he had compassion
for my nothingness. And please remember, when you go to drum and teen, he's going to have
compassion on our nothingness. But we all have to we'll prepare you for this. We all
have to go there absolutely in our nothingness for him to take over. So he's moved to compassion
for our nothingness. He came remaining with me to pray, loving and repairing together
with me. And then he said, my daughter, the more the soul strips herself of herself, that's
her ego. The more I clothe her with myself, it's about as simple as that. The surrender
that we've got to make is this ego. We've got to surrender it to him. The more she believes
she could do nothing, the more I act in her. Now that leaves all of you new teachers without
excuse. If you say you can't do it, you don't feel you can't do it and all the rest cheer
up. The more she believes she can do nothing, the more I will act in her. It's a case of
opening up to him. And that's going to be the miracle of drum and teen. That little
people acknowledging their nothingness will open up and let the Lord do whatever he wants
to do. He said, and I do everything. It's not fantastic. I feel all my love, my prayers
and my reparations being placed in act by the soul. And to give honor to myself, I listen
to whatever she does. She wants to love. I go to her and I love together with her. She
wants to pray. I pray with her. In some, her stripping and her love, which is mine, bind
me and force me to do with her whatever she wants to do. There, it is simple. I want him
to explain this to you because I'm useless. So what does he do? He explains it. So do
I have to be clever? No. In some, her stripping and her love, which is mine, bind me and force
me to do with her whatever she wants to do. And I give to the soul the merit of my love,
of my prayers and of my reparations and to my highest contentment, I feel my life being
repeated. And I make the effects of my operating descent for the good of all. Notice the universalism
there because it's not of the creature. It's mine. You see, the marvel is that when we surrender
to the divine will, it really is his work. It's not ours. And that's exactly what we need.
If everything we say and do in dramantine is his and not ours, we are going to be astonished
by this tsunami of grace. That's the reason why we're gathering. So let's take July the
4th, 1917. All the pains of creatures were suffered before by Jesus. This is terribly
important now when you have your arthritic pains and your dispains and your that pains
and your the other pains. He did it before you. One who does the divine will is together
with Jesus in the tabernacle. So we've got two topics here. So Louisa says continuing
in my usual state, I was feeling a little in suffering and my adorable Jesus and coming
placed himself in front of me. And it seemed that between me and Jesus, there were many
electric wires of communication. It's not wonderful. Now, the reason why I think it's
wonderful is not just that it's the spiritual message is that it's 1917 and they've only
just discovered electricity. And as soon as a discovery comes up, you'll find them referred
to in the writings. It's really lovely to see that. So Jesus said, my daughter, each
pain that the soul suffers is one more communication that the soul acquires. Please put some big
kind of a notice on that. Each pain. Because when we begin to understand this, you won't
be running for the panitar. You'll be running for divine currency instead. Okay. In fact,
all the pains that the soul could suffer were suffered before by me in my humanity. Okay.
So I take this painful back that I have and immediately, I do it even before I get out
of bed in the morning, because getting out of the bed is part of the problem. I say, my
back with yours in your discouraging in your divine will to cleanse everyone, cleanse everyone.
And there you have put an investment in the bank before you put your foot on the floor.
I do it before the pavilion acting before everything else. Don't even wait. All your
pains are very important. Now that doesn't mean that if you have something drastic wrong
with you, that you shouldn't go and get medical help, you should, you know, but just don't
run for the pan at all every time. So all the pains that the soul could suffer were suffered
before by me in my humanity and took their place in the divine order. Look at that. All
my pains in him and through him took their place in the divine order. I like that. That
means I don't have a problem with my back. Now do you get it? I have a privilege. I don't
have a problem. And since the person cannot suffer them all together, my goodness communicates
them little by little. Apparently, as you grow older, he seems to think you can take
more. And as it communicates them, the chains of union with me keep growing. He's not fantastic.
And not only with pains, but with anything good that the creature can do. Now look at
the little word anything. That's terribly important because St. Therese of Liz Yu said
that if you pick up a pin from the floor with a desire of making an act of pure love for
God, that that tiny action which nobody will even notice is she said it's better than all
the projects on the planet. Because it's the pure love of God. Now, Therese was before
the divine will. So do it for pure love of God and in the divine will and the good is
immeasurable. So Jesus said, so do the links of connection
developed between me and her. It's not fantastic. So every difficulty I have physical, emotional,
mental and spiritual, all of them are links to his passion.
Louisa said, another day I was thinking to myself of the good that other souls receive
by being in front of the most blessed. So here's the second topic. And she said, I'm
the poor one deprived of it. And blessed Jesus told me, she wasn't deprived of it continuously
because eventually they allowed her to have the blessed sacrament in her room. Jesus said,
my daughter, one who does my will, actually they actually mean lives in my divine will.
Is together with me in the tabernacle. Why? Because Jesus is present in the tabernacle
body blood, soul and divinity. And you're, you're fused with him in the divinity. So
of course you're with him in the tabernacle. It's just that we have to become aware of
the reality. They're together with me in the tabernacle and they take part in my pains
in the coldness, in the irreverence and in everything, which the very souls, which souls
do who are in my presence. So souls, people going to church and acting irreverently towards
the blessed sacrament, and you're in the divine will, you are allowed to make reparation for
that. So make sure that you're not the one complaining about what the others are doing.
Because if you're doing the complaining, you've slipped out at the divine will. Is that okay?
And I can tell you from the book of Exodus that the one thing that the Lord hates more
than anything else is grumbling and murmuring and complaining. He actually punished the people
in the desert several times, just for grumbling and complaining. Why? Because it's the exact
opposite of turning to him in humility, asking him for help. They should have said, give
us this day our daily bread and saying, why did God bring us out into the wilderness to
die of starvation in the wilderness? And it would have taken only a second to say, give
us this day our daily bread. Now Irish people are very prone to complaining. We say, should
I'm only telling you now? I'm only telling you. And somebody ought to do this with some
of you, of course. That's the grumbling and complaining and finding fault. The Lord hates
that because all of that is the opposite of love. So I'm only pointing that out so that
we become aware of things we can slip into without even thinking about it because it's
accepted all around us as the way people respond. So here we are. And we can participate in
making reparation to the Lord.
One who does my will, lives in the divine will, this is a number two, must excel in everything.
Now I didn't write that, I'm only reading it. You must excel in everything. Why? Because
the divine will is the highest level of spirituality that a soul can reach. That's why I have
to excel. And the place of honor is always reserved for her. Therefore, who receives
more good. The one who is before me that is physically present in the church. Or one who
is with me. Of course, the one who is with him. For one who lives in my will, I do not
tolerate even one step of distance between me and her. Or division of pains or of joys.
I may keep her on the cross, but it's always with me. And you have heard endlessly that
Louisa says suffering is one thing, but suffering when Jesus is there is quite another better
altogether. This is why then I want you always in my will. I want to give you the first place
over my sacramental heart. Look at that. Therefore, adoration for us is breathing. Okay. I want
to feel your heart palpitating in mine with my own love and pain. Not just with human
love, with divine love. I want to feel your will in mine, which multiplying in everyone
may give me with one single act, the reparations of all and the love of all. And my will in
yours, which making your poor humanity, my own, may elevate it before the majesty of
the father as a continuous victim. Look what he's prepared to do with our absolute nothing.
Now, I'm going to stop there and give you a break.